لينا من رام الله اللواء الركن المتقاعد
واصف عريقات الخبير في الشؤون
الاستراتيجيه والعسكريه لواء واصف
عريقات الجيش الاسرائيلي يتحدث عن انجازات
في جنوب قطاع غزه كيف تصف هذه
الانجازات يعني هو يتحدث عن انجازات من
وجهه نظره حقيقه ولكن من وجهه نظر قياداته
التي ارسلته لتحقيق الاهداف وهي القضاء
على المقاومه الفلسطينيه وتحرير الاسرى
بالقوه العسكريه هذا لم يح لم يحدث يعني
ما يجري اختي العزيزه الان على الارض واضح
واضح اي الجيش الاسرائيلي رغم انه يتخبط
لديه خطط حتى الان غير واضحه ولكن كما جاء
في تقرير مراسلتكم قبل قليل الجيش
الاسرائيلي يعد يحاول جس النبض اي منطقه
يمكن ان يستقر فيها في المستقبل هل هي في
الشمال الغربي في الشمال الشرقي في الشرق
او في الجنوب ما زال حتى الان
يستطلع القدرات عند المقاومه الفلسطينيه
لا يوجد لديه معلومات حقيقيه حتى الان
لذلك هو يقتل هو يدمر هو يجرف هو يعتقل
عدد كبير من المدنيين للتحقيق معهم للوصول
الى معلومات حقيقيه عن قيادات المقاومه
وقدرات المقاومه فبالتالي اذا ما كان يريد
انشاء منطقه عازله فهو يحاول يحاول ان
يهيئ لها بعض المساحات الجغرافيه ام ولا
ولكن هناك مقاومه باسله منتشره في كل
المناطق تشتبك معه في كل مكان تمنعه
وتحرمه من من تنفيذ اهدافه بالمناسبه اختي
العزيزه كل مخططاتهم وانسحابات مبنيه على
فشلهم في تحقيق الاهداف التي انطلقوا من
اجلها لذلك هم يتحدثون عن قتل مقاتلين
يعني وهم لا لا يعطون الدليل على ذلك
يتحدثون عن تفجير فتحات انفاق صحيح ان بعض
فتحات الانفاق التي هم يعرفوها التي جاؤوا
اليها عام 2014 ولكن الانفاق المستحدثه ما
بعد 2014 اعتقد انهم لا يعرفون عنها شيء
لذلك هم يبحثون عنها وهم في سباق مع الزمن
هناك ضغط عليهم اولا الخسائر مرتفعه عدم
تحقيق الاهداف الروح المعنويه تتدنى
الكفاءه القتاليه عند الجنود ايضا اي
تنخفض الامريكي الامريكي يريد الاسرائيلي
ان ينتقل الى المرحله التاليه والمرحله
التاليه في ذهن الامريكي مختلفه تماما عن
المرحله التاليه في ذهن الاسرائيلي طيب
ساعود الى ماذا تختلف وكيف تختلف ولكن
ننوه الى هذين العاجل الذين وردا قبل قليل
الخارجيه الفلسطينيه تتحدث عن اختطاف
رضيعه من قطاع غزه وان ذلك يشكل دليلا على
ارتكاب جيش الاحتلال افضع الج جرائم دون
محاسبه دون محاسبه كما اضافت الخارجيه
الفلسطينيه بمطالبه سلطات الاحتلال بتسليم
الرضيعه المختطفه بشكل رسمي للسلطه
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه فورا اعود اليك كنت
تتحدث عن ان الاهداف المرحله الثالثه
تختلف ما بين اسرائيل والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه كيف تختلفان وكيف ترى هذه
التحركات التي تحدثت عنها الزميله نجوان
على الحدود الشماليه لاليات وشاحنات
اسرائيليه يعني واضح انه هم يسحبون القوات
التي لا لزوم لها والتي اصبحت وجودها على
الارض
كلفه وخسائر امام المقاومين الفلسطينيين
اما بالنسبه لاوجه الخلاف انا اعتقد
الامريكي يريد من الاسرائيلي تقليص تقليص
التوغل البري هو هو قلق على الجيش
الاسرائيلي ليس قلق على الفلسطينيين القلق
على هيبه الجيش الاسرائيلي وعلى ذهابه من
هزيمه الى هزيمه اكبر لانه توغل الجنود
الاسرائيليين حتى الان بعد مرور 88 يوم
دون تحقيق الاهداف هزيمه هزيمه للجيش
الاسرائيلي ومزيد من الخسائر في صفوف
الجنود الاسرائيليين واكثر من ذلك الخسائر
في الاليات المعدات وفي منها معدات
امريكيه يعني ه هذه ايضا تضرب سمعه
الصناعات الصناعات الامريكيه هناك شركات
امريكيه الان
بدات بدات تتحدث عن الصناعه الفلسطينيه
هذه الاسلحه المتواضعه كيف كيف تقضي على
هذه الدبابات المركاز غاليه الثمن
الجرافات الامريكيه الاليات المجنزره ايضا
امريكيه فبالتالي المعركه لا تقتصر فقط
على فشل الجندي في الميدان ايضا فشل في كل
مناحي الحياه وخاصه في مجال التصنيع
العسكري واصف عريقات الخبيره في الشؤون
الاستراتيجيه والعسكريه كنت معنا من رام
الله شكرا لك